so for people out there who may not
listening who may not know tell me
explain to me who you are and what your
background is well I'm all being in
first off and I'm involved with the
Gambino family since I'm a kid so
literally since I'm a young kid and I
moved down here to Tampa back and forth
from New York to Tampa Florida to set up
some businesses which I did I set up a
parking company I set up nightclubs
glass companies and I base down here
bookmaking and we ran things back and
forth from Florida down back to the East
Coast okay what now what specifically
what specifically did you do like in
your height of being involved in all
this and being involved with the Gambino
family and what what are you
specifically known for well I was known
as in a four so the Gambino family
specifically I worked later on in years
for the Gotti family directly and was
there in four so they're killer they're
the guy that went that you didn't want
to see if they got a problem with us
okay so obviously if you're admitting
you were a killer and you're sitting
here right now not behind bars how did
that happen I wasn't jailed many years
temple actually my case was based out of
Tampa Florida although I was a New
Yorker and born and raised in New York
we expand the business down here to
Florida and Middle District of Florida
end up sending an indictment RICO case
against me and I went on a lot on the
run which they say on the lam took
probably about 20 countries and
eventually I was caught in Brazil by
Interpol and imprisoned in Brazil for
two and a half years fighting
extradition back to this country which
eventually they got me back here and I
did the circuit of prisons in Tampa
between Falkenberg and now Hernandez
County Pinellas County Hillsborough Lake
County I've been in all these jails he
at Miami MCC so I'm very familiar with
the system in in Florida Miami Tampa
area okay and what were you what exactly
were you locked up for I was charged for
drug-dealing murders murder conspiracies
assaults and just a slew of everything
which they bottle up in what they call
Rico I was involved in a Rico
racketeering case and with the Gambino
family and considered a street boss holy
[ __ ]
okay so how did you get out of prison if
you had a murder charge how did you beat
a murder charge amongst all of these
other in st. charges well when I was
down in Brazil when Interpol catches me
I'm doing - about two years two and a
half years there well I did exactly two
and a half years there and I was brought
back here on Christmas Eve 2006 almost
2007 extradition law is a 30-year
sentence between countries so I'm facing
life here once I left the country if in
order for them to bring me back the
maximum time I can get on that
extradition treaty is the maximum life
sentence in Brazil which is 30 years so
once they bring me back into 30 year
term and how old were you about 25 on
that I was uh in my 40s in about 40 41
years old one day when they grabbed me
okay with a 30 year sentence well
probably two that I've been in and out
of prisons basically my adult life so I
was in and out did a three and a half
year bid on a gun charge I did some
assault charges I did six months a year
three months three months violations
bribery cases so I'm accustomed to the
system
Wow and so it seems like you obviously
got a lot of time knocked off that
sentence right I mean how did you get
all that time knocked out well once I
come back to Tampa Florida well before I
come back to Tampa Florida there's a
couple of guys that were involved me
Associates of mine that fly down to
Brazil and they give me paper work on
certain guys in the Gambino family
wanted them being the son of John Gotti
senior the boss at a Gambino family from
the 90s 80s to the 90s who dies in
prison but his son was what they call
queen of the day so queen of the day is
somebody that walks into the government
makes a deal with them to give up crime
criminal activity and he's free to talk
about anything can't get charged with
that at the same time giving up
activities of associates members of the
Gambino family or of other organizations
and other families so that was a guess
around 2005 2004 2005 there abouts while
I was in those Penitentiary's Gotti son
Gotti Jr was queen of the day he was
queen of the day meaning that he talked
to the FBI and got full protection from
them yes good exactly cooperating most
people don't know what that is and then
it translates into what they call a 302
I mean you're never gonna get all the
documents of Frey what he was talking
about but the thing is he met with the
government he started cooperating yeah
how old were you and you started getting
involved with these guys I was a kid my
father was involved with my uncle in uh
in a gambling business my uncle was a
ran a game called three-card Monte in
the Bronx with Charlie Luciano was a
very famous gangsters named Lucky
Luciano
the cousin of Charlie Luciano Blackie
was my uncle's partner so I would be at
those games at five six years old and
probably two I mean after that Andy
Russia ah know was the boss in my
neighborhood and the Ruggiano was a
quiet dawn in my neighborhood he was a
the guy that ran our area for the
Gambino family very famous gangster he
was straightened out or became a made
member of the Mafia through Albert
Anastasia Albert Anastasia was murdering
he's also very famous gangster killer I
hung around that family
to play baseball with them box with them
went to the gym with them
yeah and became very familiar with the
ways of the Mafia being quiet and
underground and despite what people see
later on in the gaudy era of the louder
than the boisterous it's not the way the
gangsters operated right for within the
mob it was a quiet organization or it's
supposed to be this right guys like Andy
Louisiana was true boss people really
don't know who it is because hind the
scenes he's very quiet yeah behind the
scenes guy so what chain of events led
up to you actually meeting the Gottis or
God he's got his senior was the first
guy you worked with right well well you
know again we're around the rosey an old
family and the morale and meeting
different gangstas it did you know like
when you when you started in your with
those guys did you know who the Gottis
were I mean now they didn't have that
name back that uh Gotti senior ends up
getting straightened out in the late 70s
his brother Jeanne a little before him a
couple years before him I don't think
they ever get that right in the media
Jeanne was actually a made number first
Jeanne Gotti Cheney got eheh and seen
you got he ends up getting the name for
himself in the early 80s in the 70s
through a murder but in the early
eighties where the public really knows
him and later on at Pat and the Ruggiano
goes to prison so senior steps in issues
and becomes the boss in our area which
is a captain and skipper at that time
okay so as time progresses yeah meeting
different mobsters and a Gambino family
and senior becomes one of the guys I
meet and junior I meet through mutual
friends we're all in the same
neighborhood so it's not really somebody
would say dia it's like living in a
Tampa area and you go to International
mall and that's where the scene is set
and everybody sees each other on a daily
basis so it's you know just a mixture of
where we live in the area and one of the
authors a writer Lou Romano talks about
you know you zip code and he zip code
determines the way of your life and our
zip code was if you can spell Oz if
called my area was one one four to one
what if you spelled it a different way
it would
be mobsters incorporated I mean it was
just gangsters around and that's how we
were raised and what specific area was
that like what specific town was that I
grew up in Woodhaven but the aligning
neighborhood so his own Park was also
against the area and Howard beaches
where the Gotti family lived okay I
don't mean nowhere Woodhaven in New York
it's New York so Queens Queens Queens
there and it's in that area it's
different townships in Queens Wow so
what was the working relationship with
you and Gotti when you guys first met
like what was the first interaction like
and how did that become a working
relationship between you guys well I was
known to be a scrappy kid probably to
that and yeah as always fight and you
were a fighter
yeah I was a fighter so he's in the gyms
browser fighter in the street more so I
wasn't a big guy was a small guy it was
good with my hands and most of the guys
from my neighborhood self you know I'm
not the only guy that was fighting in
our neighborhood everybody fights
whether the good fighters are not they
fight okay and Jamaica Avenue where I
was from was more of a poverty-stricken
area lower middle class I guess low
class depending on where you live
Jamaica Avenue McGavin oh god it's
Queens okay and where the Gottis lived
well how a beach was more of a money
area so some of those kids from that
area would come up to Jamaica Avenue
where the Rue Giotto family was from and
where I was from and name started
nickname in I area for the violence it
was and death Haven instead of what
Haven and Wow so as time progresses the
kids are all meeting each other through
sports through activities to you know
different things and gaudi's would
wanted to names it and one of the
families that were around the area would
come up to our area and we started
mixing with each other and continued and
criminal at the price we were all on the
streets either selling drugs moving
money
bookmaking hurting guys and hustling so
wow that was our everyday life I mean
this is what goes on in high areas okay
so so you guys kind of like you guys rub
shoulders you guys know a lot of the
same people and then how did he did heat
was he the one that approached you and
said hey I want you to be my hit man or
did he say hey I got a job for you how
did he introduce you into the into wells
life he was dealing drugs with another
guy johnny gaba through
in a pot and small stuff not really
small levels but you know nothing major
major truckloads but you know a hundred
pounds they were buying at a time 200
pounds you know something like that and
that was his partner and gabot also knew
me and lived around a corner from me so
I first moved meet the Sun that way the
father I meet through some of his
associates and all the guys and through
his son and I start mixing with them the
big heroin movies and they asked me to
get involved in a heroin trade so I
start slowly getting involved in heroin
besides besides a pot business marijuana
cocaine and like any business you expand
so you starting one drug and we're
expanding all over and I'm moving drugs
okay from a small level to a big level
okay and from there I just step into the
violence it's just a slow process of so
you started making quite a bit of money
moving drugs oh yeah where we'll make a
mone big really yeah we come in from you
know I was probably at the time I was
talking about a million a month and the
whole you know and I think that's low
ball and being conservative
so the different guys that were around
what I was did interviews and said that
that numbers not right it's higher than
that guys that actually were my friends
and later on became my enemies guys I
shot that spoke up and did interviews
and said I think John's on the plane the
amount of money they were making and how
violent he was but I mean everybody's
gonna have an opinion of what was
accurate or what wasn't but the the
accurate number I think is safe to say
about a million a month holy crap and
how did you transmit so what what
transitions you for making money dope
dealing to like were you actually like
getting paid to execute people well it
doesn't really work like that I don't
know how it works I'll give you I'll
give you an example on the drug deal
you're a drug dealer somebody tells me
you're moving drugs in an a but it's not
that I'm sitting at pedaling you know
quota keys keys grams on the corner
there's people that are working for us
and if they tell me that about a guy
like yourself will approach you find out
what you're doing and you told to do
business with us for us and I'll give
you a guys that run around the street if
you don't do business with
you know you're gonna jump it eyes
yourself whether you're gonna get hurt
or killed depending on what you do and
so in the in the middle of I was doing
business every day business guys are
getting killed guys are getting shot
guys are getting hurt expand up business
to expand the business I always expand
it's always to preserve it anybody it's
challenging it and it's not just a drug
business it's the same for the sports
business Union business so depending on
what the issue is
you know whoever's in charge at the time
whether it's you know a fatty and
erosion or whether it's Gotti or
whoever's calling the shots
they'll delegate work to guys like me
and different guys to go out and we you
know either collect that money shooting
guys moving drugs book bacon and hustle
in the street so will controlling our
streets under the flag of the Gambino
family and this is everyday life for us
[Laughter]